what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest craziest updates in a
demon slayer story if you enjoyed these
weekly Demon Slayer videos make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or else you
won't know when future Demon Slayer
videos come out to help me decide what
Demon Slayer videos you want me to make
in the future follow me on instagram at
anime uproar of course there will be
manga spoilers in this video I'm gonna
be talking about the latest chapter
chapter 192 after all now without
further ado let's jump into it we start
this chapter with what I was wondering
about last chapter namely what in tundra
nasi before getting out of his coma asks
state we know he viewed the memories of
his ancestor and saya Ichi but we didn't
know the full extent of it thankfully
this chapter starts out by letting us
know exactly what time zero saw before
the encounter with Musa and the
information is huge you guys know that I
also love you at e3 so I'm always
thankful when we get more scenes with
him in them after series finishes I'm
going to have to make the definitive
video on your ichi including everything
there is to know about him this chapter
has been translated as revolving
connection and we'll see why that's oh
so significant as I predicted tendril
can learn a lot from seeing your ichi in
action in his ancestors memories he's
heard the explanation many times but
seeing you teach he actually performed a
breath of the Sun forms makes a big
difference his understanding goes up he
reveals that stuff like slight
differences in wrist angle the
difference in hand placement and getting
a sense of the breathing made him
realize how much his own movements were
lacking this is extremely interesting
before we could have assumed that the
breath of the Sun was passed down
perfectly from you at each Chi through
the dance of the fire-god style but this
was clearly not the case thus that means
that despite how strong Tiger was
against Icaza there's an even higher
level of power that ton zero can reach
that means that as I guess awaken Tundra
will have gotten a significant upgrade
over pre fainting kanjiru but let's get
back to the memories for now we're given
more information about your Ichi
he was a quiet and humble person which
is really cool because he was by far the
most talented demon ser ever so he had a
right to be
and if anyone did but he wasn't which
just makes me respect him more tsuzuku
son would ask your ichi to show her the
sword forms and he graciously did thus
the world pretty much has sui ACOTA
thank for humanity's last hope for
beating musa Sumiyoshi the ancestor who
looks just like kanjiru concentrated on
yuri cheese movements he looked
carefully so as not to miss even one
moment the breath of the sun' style was
set to be breathtakingly beautiful time
zero could understand why they were
later replicated with the dance with a
sword your teacher was said to resemble
a spirit more than a human which is an
interesting thing to say it reminds me
of the selfless state no humanly
emotions like fighting spirit hatred or
killing intent are present it's almost
as if you're Ichi has stopped being
human while he's using the sword style
he's become one with the universe he's
not doing anything per se he just is
tsuzuku and a child loved seeing the
beautiful sword style and udg bad has
had bashfully yet Ichi truly has the
qualities of a saint ultimate power and
ultimate humility rolled into one being
although he was told to visit again it
seemed like he wouldn't since Julie she
left behind his earrings Sumi Yoshi was
sad to see him go he told you at Ichi
that he'll take over with the lives you
reach he saved in other words your ichi
saved their lives and thus the lives of
their future descendants through this
act your ichi eventually will indirectly
beat musa assume he or she tells him
that he is not a man of no work as your
ichi sometimes thinks he is Sumiyoshi
tells him not to think that he didn't do
anything he promises to pass down the
earrings and the breath of the Sun to
future generations
in response URI she gives him a very
rare smile and he thanks Sumiyoshi it's
a touching moment and as we know now
Sumiyoshi kept his promise he passed on
the breath of the sun' style through the
dance of the fire-god the dance was
passed down through the family all the
way down to tan judo as I said before
tundra is clearly the successor of not
only your ichi style but of his will
which is to lessen human suffering by
defeating Mouzon once and for all
tonzura goes on to thank you ichi and
acknowledges that if not for him saving
his ancestors he and his family never
could have been born your TV in a very
real sense might end up stopping Musa
as he wanted to he felt that Alice's
life's purpose but he couldn't do it in
his lifetime
still though he saved Tundras ancestors
and showed them the breath of the Sun
style
so if tundra does beat Mouzon which is
probably gonna happen
your teaches life made that possible in
that case you're DG did achieve his
life's purpose even if he had to die
before it was fully completed
furthermore let me mention that that
angle ku also saved tangelo so we'll be
able to say that he also played a vital
role in moves ons to feet went on Jenner
eventually beats him that amazing
firebender sacrifice will not be in vain
his life was definitely not a waste time
she also points out how Tama Yeol played
an important role that helped them push
moves on this farm and she was only able
to do that because you'd eat she freed
her from Musa and spared her life maybe
your each he didn't kill moves on
directly but he laid the groundwork for
his eventual defeat while he was alive
as time zero mentions it was only
because of you to each his breath of the
Sun style that Tundra has any hope of
beating Mouzon we're told that the
breath of the Sun forms were passed down
with amazing accuracy despite the
passing of hundreds of years all 12
known forms are listed off then the 13th
form is finally mentioned the thirteenth
form that's been hyped up for so long as
a way to beat Musa it is mentioned how
Kendra's father danced the dance of the
fire-god until dawn way back during the
fight against the Rui
we got a flashback about Tundras dad
time zero was shocked how he could dance
for so long and his dad told him that
there's a special way of breathing that
lets you never get tired no matter how
long you move he told punch of that if
he learned how to breathe properly he
would be able to dance forever the
craziest thing is that Tundras dad was
sick at this point and he still managed
the dance for so long now it all seems
to be coming together all the pieces of
the puzzle are falling into place this
is exactly what times our needs
he is obviously tired and injured but
because of the properties of the dance
of the fire-god this doesn't matter
he needs to last the seemingly
impossible hour against moves on until
the Sun comes up but it's actually
possible to dancer the fire-god that his
father was able to perform until dawn in
the past tundra then figures out when he
sees through moves ons body that the
13th and final form is actually the
twelve forms he already knows
period in succession I really like this
twist rather than being this brand new
thing the 13th form was something that
puncher already possessed he just didn't
know it he decides that he'll use the
dance of the fire-god to cut Milan's
hearts and brains until dawn again
contra doesn't know if he can do it he
says that he doesn't possess your DG's
and his father's skill he doesn't even
know if he can stay alive until dawn he
doesn't know how to prevent Mouzon from
escaping when he uses that escape method
where he explodes into 1,800 plus pieces
of flesh he questions whether he could
do something you DT himself couldn't
namely defeat Mouzon I like this part
because it shows us a few things one it
shows us that Conchita was humble like
UHG second and lets us know that hunter
is uncertain about the outcome and even
considers it more likely that he won't
be able to do it thirdly he's gonna try
to do it anyways unlike the flame pillar
who lost confidence he will embrace the
uncertainty and give it his best shot I
really appreciate that about Tanja he's
not going around screaming that he's the
strongest Demon Slayer ever and he's not
sure about the outcome but he's still
brave enough to give it his best shot
this is something we can all resonate
with because in life difficult
situations will pop up then the choice
is ours well we'd be like the flame
pillar of the past and give up or will
we be like ton zero and give it our best
shot even if our chances of winning are
not good
remember to quote you miss 100% of the
shots you don't take
tonzura is willing to take the shot he
promises that he will give his best to
do what he can do we see it in Goku Suba
and Tanja reminds himself to keep his
heart burning as an in Goku would again
when Goku sacrifice made this moment
possible and furthermore his example
even helped inspire ton zero Hunter goes
on to attack moves on and the battle
heats up once more Muslims PTSD kicks in
he looks at control and he sees genichi
looking back at him and he says a ghost
which is funny since he's pretty much
like a vampire
but even he has something he's afraid of
tundra gets hit suddenly but he learns
an important lesson
Musa can change shape and so his strikes
come in unexpected ways you cannot fight
him as if
had a fixed form control also counts 19
tentacles that moves on is using to
fight which is just crazy
the fact that anyone could survive 19
unpredictable randomly moving tentacles
is practically unimaginable Tantra
though is able to do it when he combines
your Ricci's forms he sees that that's
how they're designed and he asks isn't
that right your Ichi
that's an awesome moment showing that
your Ichi is very much present in this
final fight against Musa by the end of
this chapter Tantra looks completely on
top of it he looks determined to use all
twelve forms in succession and win what
an amazing chapter this was to say that
things are really heating up now would
be an understatement this chapter was on
fire we got some crazy important updates
and reveals including the one about
Tundras final xiii form some things are
still uncertain
we know that demon slayer is always full
of complications and as Zuko hasn't even
shown up yet there's no way that Pancho
will just succeed in fighting moves on
alone like this until dawn especially
since he admitted himself that he
doesn't know how to prevent him from
escaping by using that method where he
explodes into a bunch of small pieces of
flesh
Tantra believes he is still a good deal
less skilled than your Ichi so it's very
unlikely that he can cut all 1,800
pieces of flesh when you're Ichi could
only cut a little more than 1,500 in my
view we will need Mexico and perhaps
send it to an auskey Cano and whoever
else can fight to help defeat moves on
for good it's will in the end probably
be a team effort even if that just means
that the others will join in in the end
to help cut all those separate pieces of
flesh I know that's any to any nosce
don't look in good shape now but if you
look back on the series you'll notice
that characters tend to regain
consciousness after such injuries and
help when the time is right just think
of the fight against Doki and Yuto but
whatever happens it does seem like the
series is really wrapping up you're each
is being brought up bringing the story
full circle and then Goku is being
brought up as well which also helps give
closure to the story if the story does
end after this fight I still think it
will be a great ending and that Demon
Slayer will go down as one of my
favorite series of all time however
there is the hope that it might continue
after all wouldn't it be
weird if our main characters developed
such powerful breath styles and became
such powerful demon Slayers only for
them all to retire at the ages of 15 and
16 it could definitely happen and all
their arcs did wrap up nicely in nosce
got revenge against DOMA Canoga revenge
against DOMA send it to God revenge
against kagaku and after this battle
tundra and the rest will have gotten
revenge against the main villain so it
wouldn't be a bad unsatisfying ending at
all but a part of me still wishes it
would an end but anyways that's it for
this video let me know you felt about
this chapter and how you feel about the
end of the series in general if you
enjoy these weekly Demon Slayer chapter
reviews and want to keep them coming
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss future chapter reviews when they
drop for more Demon Slayer content and
to help decide what videos I make in the
future follow me on instagram at anime
uproar a special thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who helped
us survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost I want to thank our the one
tier patrons the ones who stay atop all
clans Steven and Greta a Lola autumn
makoto-kun the world stealers the school
bus and Tyson Kirino and I can't forget
our pro hero tier patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson King zelgius $30 beat alpha do
Anatoli Kazansky angel Cruz team Sparky
65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor Jessica
Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy Edward
Vargas Jeanne d'Arc and Joel Stanton
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you get support more by going over
to patreon calm and pro and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these epic
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talked about anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
and until next time see a space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]